[Música]
casi cuatro meses después antioquía
sigue siendo una gigantesca zona en
construcción antes del terremoto había
tres edificios residenciales donde Ahora
solo hay escombros no queda nada de los
120 apartamentos el gobernador contrató
empresas privadas para limpiar los
escombros los obreros han estado
trabajando durante semanas
aquí hay muchos escombros de edificios
que se desplomaron
y alrededor hay muchos edificios que
resultaron gravemente afectados
la gobernación autorizó su demolición
luego habrá que reconstruirlos
para esta obra en particular necesitamos
unos tres o cuatro meses
el gobierno Turco prometió reconstruirlo
todo en un año y Calcula que más de
300.000 edificios deberán ser
reconstruidos en la región
en el centro histórico de antioquía y
pasar recupera sus colores poco a poco
pero su corazón aún no late como antes
pues todos saben lo que les pasó a
aquellos cuyos negocios siguen cerrados
este restaurante reabrió sus puertas
hace pocos días desde los años 60 sirve
especialidades locales
tengo 60 años Tengo que trabajar perdí
mi casa y tengo bocas que alimentar
aunque no hay mucho movimiento el
restaurante volvió a abrir sus puertas
Gracias a que algunos empleados
regresaron
estuve tres meses en ankara me dijeron
que iban a reabrir Así que volví
pero no en todas partes hay agua y
electricidad
no hay donde dormir lo que es un gran
problema
normal de bien bebé normalmente somos un
equipo de 25 personas Pero ahora solo
somos 10
la mayoría de nuestros colegas se fueron
a otras ciudades
[Música]
esta falta de mano de obra es el reto
más importante al que se enfrenta a la
provincia de hatay lejos del centro nos
encontramos con el presidente de la
cámara de comercio como se quedó sin
oficina suele tener sus reuniones aquí
necesitamos hospitales
necesitamos
escuelas
necesitamos contenedores o alojamientos
necesitamos muchas cosas
por eso la mayoría de la gente no volvió
y esta situación podría ser permanente
lo que provocará cambios demográficos en
Turquía
según él el 70% de los lugares de
trabajo comercios negocios y oficinas de
su provincia sufrieron daños el estado
está invirtiendo mucho dinero para
facilitar el realojamiento pero para
hitman chinchin queda mucho por hacer en
el ámbito socioeconómico
las ayudas que nos prometieron para
reorganizar la región hacer la atractiva
de nuevo e invertir la tendencia
migratoria está muy lejos de ser
suficientes
según la asamblea de exportadores turcos
las 11 regiones afectadas representaron
casi el 10% de las exportaciones del
país el año pasado
no solo textiles metalurgia y productos
químicos sino también productos
agrícolas como la famosa miel de adana
esta es la madre la reina como todo el
mundo las abejas tienen una madre la
reina de La Colmena
este año vemos que vamos a perder hasta
el 50% de las abejas y por tanto de la
producción de miel el estado debe
invertir esta industria saldrá
gravemente perjudicado
aquí como en el resto de las regiones
afectadas la situación es la misma este
miembro del sindicato Turco de
apicultores la mente los daños que ha
sufrido las empresas y sus medios de
producción
los daños fueron peores de lo que
teníamos
6.500 colmenas resultaron destruidas en
la región
Pero al menos el gobierno prometió
darnos nuevas cajas para reemplazar las
colmenas
y azúcar gratis para alimentar a las
abejas
lejos de las grandes ciudades el
concreto y los escombros Esta es la otra
cara de estas zonas afectadas por la
catástrofe donde la destrucción es menos
visible pero igual de Real
[Música]